Lindsey Vonn is in the man cave here
she's got a new book strong as the new
beautiful yeah I know
embrace your natural beauty eat clean
and harness your power now available
wherever books are sold
I the Dan ants have already had one
comment about you right away okay you
ready for this yeah I don't know baby
your your your handshake yeah firm well
duh yeah well no that's the way it's
supposed to be I know but my guys look
at him there a little bit feeble and
they're like well that's a that's a
that's a handshake there I mean business
yeah Paulie you know Adrian Peterson the
football player he has that handshake
Rio whoa yeah it hurts she gives you an
Adrian Peterson desk handshake yeah
which is impressive who taught you to
that handshake my father yeah Larry go
there yeah okay
that's like are you it Midwest yeah I
like where you from in the Midwest
Minnesota okay are you a Viking fan you
know no you're not who do you root for
I love AP but um uh yeah I'm a Broncos
girl Oh since you relocated fail and
they're good well I mean I I've lived in
Colorado since I was 12 so it's not like
I just jumped ship do you go to games
huh wrote a couple pregame preseason
games this year and I haven't been back
for a couple weeks so I haven't been yet
but were you a skier in Minnesota and
then realized that I find me to do this
I got to relocate to a place where I can
scale the time of great great places
yeah exactly
um I grew up skiing in Buck Hill
Minnesota it's like 300 vertical feet
it's nothing
slow molehill like a bunny bunny yeah
basically um it's less than the bunny
slope where I get now in Vail we were
also wondering can you go at let's say
your girlfriends aren't very good skiers
but they say hey let's go skiing yeah I
don't have any of those that can't ski
all your friends are really good well I
grew up skiing with most of them oh
that's how I have okay what if you met a
guy who wasn't very good at skiing okay
have you ever had a date where you've
gone skiing but you can't go on the
black diamond or double diamond or
whatever those things are um not really
I think
would you date a guy who couldn't ski
well yeah of course okay I think I think
I mean I hope I would have the patience
to teach him I would try really hard
definitely try to teach him but can you
ski casually of course I do
I like ski with my brother all the time
especially in the spring and he can't
ski no he can ski my brother can ski do
you do like the pizza did you ever do
that growing up I learned to do that no
one does the peak they don't what do
they do unless you're like really a
beginner do you do the pizza as I
returned I have done it yeah I have done
it but do you only do the pizza do you
do french fries come on dude you do
french fries don't you know I just pizza
guy how much do you cost for an hour how
could you whoa wait a minute
I said hold on go to the day and the
podcast that that won't be in the
podcast Matt Lauer didn't ask you that
that's my friend the show's better okay
I have no chance of being your friend
after that it's okay man okay second
chance here we go how much for two hours
skiing okay thank you for putting that
in there um I don't know no one's ever
asked me nobody's ever rented you to be
eschewed instructor I don't know if I'm
up for rent or not I don't know I mean I
do events with sponsors and stuff yeah
but um and I ski with a lot of people
for a course of four or five hours but
it's a lot of money
can you teach people how to do what you
do how long would it take I don't know
if I have that kind of patience yeah no
no I understand I could I mean like I
coach little kids you know if I I'm
training with kids that are next to me I
I'll give him some pointers and stuff I
do so in French run yeah you know I I
don't know if I could actually teach
someone to do what I do specifically you
know if they're not a racer I could
definitely try to help them learn how to
ski but I'm not I don't know I I lack
patience can you come on my stop see
good how do you get over fear I don't
fear but how do you get past that I just
don't have it it's just not there you
have a conscience yes yes yeah but but
do you think at any point how fast I'm
going now
never why would you do that I don't know
do you think at all when you're racing
um I think about how I can go faster and
if I made a mistake where I can make up
the time I don't only think about too
much the more the more you have in your
head the harder it is to focus on what
you're doing at that moment
what's it like to go fast I always say
if you're driving down the highway stick
your head out the window not obviously
if you're driving but that's what it
feels like it's the wind in your face
it's like it's fast it feels really fun
it's the funnest thing I can like think
of to do in the world but you don't
think no you can't think no that's what
you do it's like preparation that's what
you do beforehand when you train you
think about what you're doing and how
you're doing it and you you visualize
the course you prepare and then one
you're actually racing it's all
automatic you're just looking for the
fastest line and trying to be the
fastest you can you can is there
trash-talking it's more chicks it's kind
of like a like don't look at me you know
it's like the death stare really yeah
it's more like a but it's kind of funny
because I can tell what girl is gonna do
well
each race body language yeah it's four
it's just and I mean it's all
psychological it's it's kind of fun
though but you play games I don't play
games I'm the same every time but you
know you can tell if the weather is bad
and girls get scared I can tell I know
what's going on I like that I like that
but you're kind of a badass when you're
when you're racing but you you have to
be like you can't be timid you can't be
no you can't ask allocated out here no
yeah you have to be a hundred percent
confident in what you're doing
how much do you bench I don't bench I
don't need our muscle oh you don't know
canal so we can't compare that do squat
yeah yeah I do like I do about five but
what I do last time what I do squats ah
25:27 303 says what do you think yeah
what do you do what do you do Scott's
one uh more than that yeah I'm sure you
do sure you do
yeah but you probably bench more than I
do by the way uh no you do I'm going
Darren I know I literally don't bench I
didn't do a hundred
I don't bench I don't think I've been in
like five or six if you can do 100 you
can do more than me I just do pull-ups
can you pull up yeah yeah I like to peel
off 25 but you know what they don't like
my breakfast when I have my shirt off
they don't like it when you go to the
club and I and I take my shirt off to do
the pull-ups like that oh no I'm not
allowed to do that I I make a lot of
noises too
you take your shirt off when you do your
pull-ups yeah yeah I mean you gotta show
them us yeah you do yeah but I like to
yell when I do okay that's weird yeah
that's just weird
no it's not when you're throwing around
iron like I am like I've been doing
pull-ups you're like you're not throwing
around I know I am but I'm throwing
around my body weight which is the iron
that's okay yeah you got them yep do you
want to stick around sure are you sure
you sure are you gonna pay me for the
hour Oh everything's negotiable how
about I'll have you for an half hour not
an hour we'll see we'll talk about the
book Lindsay Vaughn's new book strong is
the new beautiful embrace your natural
beauty eat clean and harness your power
why not just strong as the new beautiful
why and leave it right there
because I wanted to give a little bit
more about what's in the book not just
like statement strong is the new
beautiful embrace your natural beauty
eat clean and harness your power harness
your power is the key key there really
yeah so being the best you you can be
that's cheesy but it's true could it
help me do this job I think so do I need
help doing this job will continue with
Lindsay Vonn and we'll do so right after
this from the Dan Patrick what's the
best compliment you can receive um that
I'm an amazing skier you want that push
here yeah so you would want something
about your job where I'm a great role
model something like that
yeah yeah and be the most
when you're anything what do you when
you write a book like this um is it
personal like you want to get something
out that can be cathartic that you've
gone through like how do you get to the
point where you say this is what I want
to do and the reason why I bring this up
Abby Wambach came in yeah and she talked
about you know alcoholism she talked
about coming out as a lesbian talking to
her parents and you know just all those
things but she felt like she needed to
get it out there instead of suppressing
it what did you need to get out that you
were suppressing I just feel like I had
a lot of lessons that I've learned over
the course of my career you know from
from what I eat to how I train and how I
feel about myself and um I mean I
haven't been at this place in this place
in my life until the last couple of
years and I like I finally figured it
out and um you know I wanted to pass
that along I wasn't I'm not ready to do
like mmm more like Abby and uh will you
do one I don't know man
my life is that good my life's
complicated that's what people want in a
memoir I know I mean I I've I've been
pretty open like I've talked about my
depression which is something similar to
Abby no I definitely felt like I needed
that to get get that off my chest but I
don't know I mean there's family stuff
and I just don't really I don't know if
a memoir is the right move for me right
now maybe later
but um I think this is the most
beneficial for others hopefully but this
is you you you go into a different world
if you write a book or who you date it's
not just in you know in the skiing
community is one thing but you stepped
into onto a bigger stage whether it was
who you dated or you know writing a book
here were you ready for that
ah I don't know I I'm ready I'm ready
for the book part you know I'm ready to
be on that stage for the book and
hopefully you know give some good advice
and be a good role model I think
it's been difficult you know who have
dated in the past and being on a
different stage so to speak and being in
the public eye and you know having
paparazzi around it's definitely
different and were you stalked um we
were for a little bit um what's your
what's your favorite still
or least favorite story know it like
walking on the beach and I didn't see
anyone
you know it's an empty beach and I could
not see anyone and a few hours later
there's pictures of me walking on the
beach like that scares me because I
don't I didn't see anyone were you
walking by yourself yes and you don't
see anybody on these pictures surface
no I scares me like I don't know where
these people were hiding where were they
well like Tom Brady is sunbathing at a
villa in Italy and they got pictures of
him well you know who wouldn't want me
it wasn't you though sorry Tom yeah it
wasn't you right maybe not we loved how
you had fun with JJ Watt on the red
carpet at the ESPYs no boy but I don't
know if hey I'm not dating him I never
dated him nothing ever happened okay no
I just I'm like hey I'm actually happy
you brought it up because so many people
are like hey man yeah JJ is pretty
awesome huh I'm like no dude nothing
happened I swear I just I actually it
was an inside joke and he is like part
of the thigh joke is what it was I think
it's what you're getting well his
physical therapists are all these like
you know middle-aged men who are rubbing
his inner thigh and so I was I was
giving him a hard time not because I was
rubbing his thigh woopi-hey because his
physical therapist old middle-aged men
were rubbing his thigh so that was the
joke clearly it did not come across very
well do you not believe me it didn't
matter you you'reyou're two single
people and I thought you're just having
fun and it was good TV negative Dan did
you think about dating JJ what no
nothing no he was my friend okay I have
a lot of friends I like friends did he
get the joke yes but his girlfriend
David that can be a problem right there
yep yeah that can be a problem alright
good dannis sorry dude yeah the dance
have a question for you each day at has
a a question
Palio start with you your question for
Lindsey Vonn III do a little
snowboarding very bad at it but I have a
buddy who skis with me and he insist on
wearing jeans whilst skiing not ski
pants of anyway but jeans like blue
jeans like I'm wearing whilst skiing
that is it cool and I know it is in no
way shape or form cool retro like bib
overalls nope no hunter percent alright
Farah that's not all righty all right
see no Connor your question for you do
you think that skiers and snowboarders
should have different mountains uh I
mean maybe it's it's nice okay so like
there are places that only allow skiers
the problem is it's so snowboarders are
difficult because you guys camp out and
you like adjust your bindings and you're
in the middle of the trail and you like
you only can see from like one side of
out of your you know your peripheral
vision is terrible so it's really
difficult for us to like maneuver and
know what's going on just say they need
to have their own mount okay man I'm
trying to be politically correct here
I do like snowboarders but it'd be super
great if we could just a little
separation
McLovin your question for Lindsey Vonn
okay the dad's had this idea a few
months ago what if they move the
Olympics from every four years to every
two years or three years would you be in
favor of that yeah that'd be awesome
the problem is that it's hard with
summer and winter olympics so you know
how would you accomplish that it takes
so much money and then now I'm not on
the Olympic extra but I believe they're
in different seasons Lindsey you are
good this might have been a bad idea
this might be a weird day hey if you can
get it done I'm all for it because it's
really hard to have it every four years
it's really hard I mean so much can
change in four years and then if you
want to go back to JJ watch growing no
you don't you don't Thanks let's we're
over that okay we're done
worst injury yeah you ever had uh my
second ACL surgery likes I messed up my
meniscus really bad they almost had to
completely remove it
um tibial plateau fracture
I was a long one I was a long rehab
process when you wake up
do you know damaged yeah it's like it's
like the squeaky wheel gets the oil
that's you know my knee it just makes a
lot of noises it's like kind of crunchy
and sometimes it's like popping noises
do you worry 15 20 years down the road
oh yeah if I'm already snap crackle
popping it right now it's gonna what's
gonna happen in 20 years but that moment
where you're leaving the mountain and
you're in the air are you can you try to
like when they're taking like when
they're evacuating me no no not that but
when you're you're actually falling yeah
do you learn how to fall in it in a way
are you going too fast it it doesn't it
you come and just you try to relax you
terrible at going 80 miles an hour where
if you're if you see the fence coming
just go limp go numb just just try to
like relax as much as you can because if
you're tight everything's gonna get
ripped are you glad you came in today
I'm this has been a very interesting
conversation that's that that's not
answering my question
well if you buy my book then I'll be
happy I joined to buy it I have it right
here
well you could buy it and help me out
I'm ready for the hour I'll take I'll
take a I'll take a book that's that's
what's gonna cost for for the hour which
actually would buy a book I'll buy a
book and I'll let my daughters read it
perfect how's that that is that is a
perfect solution
McLovin wants to arm-wrestle you by the
way
III don't know if I I don't lift arms
like I just do pull-ups I don't know if
I'd be good at it but we could try
alright
McLovin I'm not doing this I don't oh
you don't want to do I think she'll be
fine am i intimidating you know you're
not you 11 did you just forfeit I think
he did oh you want you sure you sure
about this Lindsey I mean I'm okay to
lose to a man but I mean are you okay to
lose to a chick huh all right here we go
huh braking hey here we go
McLovin Dartmouth friend where are we
doing this is happening right now yeah
yes to do
like right here right do it over in the
kitchen by the way Lindsey Vaughn's new
book is strong as the new beautiful nice
your time my children eat clean harness
your power it's all about power Lindsey
I mean I could I suppose it's all about
power harness your power Lindsey okay
here we go
it's available wherever books are sold
so Lindsey Vonn one of the more
decorated skiers in history against
McLovin whoo all right someone say three
two I'm gonna say three to Howard anyway
get out of this know I'm about the
notaire are you ready no once again the
book is strong is the new beautiful
three oh no the two one what is that
do you think that she lets you win she
wants to throw that did you see it up
put any pressure there what are you
doing
be nice oh I can't make you guys look at
GU fun man now you really got into his
head Lindsey she just threw an arm
recognize Marie she did didn't do that
to the Russians and she come back over
show what not your groin like again why
what did happen today
the the book is as strong as the new
beautiful embracing your natural beauty
eat clean and harness your power I don't
know if you'll ever come back you don't
have to rock you don't have to write a
book to come back but we would love to
have you come back you were great sport
thank you yeah maybe we'll try it in a
different sport
let me try like ping-pong or something
next time can you think lemon oh I'll
actually try next time yes
actually no that good with that why no
next time pull-ups oh forget it
there's no way oh yeah yeah I don't
think I would hold back and then but
you're a machine
I mean you work out your that's my job
Oh like you know you guys talking the
radio on your mancave
I workout by the way I do agree to buy
three books for her to throw
that armored us see it's been a
productive morning yeah yeah
you've sold four books today unto me and
three to McLovin
well worth it she's Lindsey Vonn you're
a great sport thank you
alright welcome back after this on the
Dan Patrick show
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience